we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's go next to our caller from the
to15 area code caller from - 1 5 go
ahead how you doing David this is a
Michael from Philadelphia great I wasn't
wondering I was wondering if you ever
consider going into politics you know
probably not and I've people have asked
me this before and I actually have
thought about it but I just think that
it would take so long for me to even
really be able to go and work my way up
into a position where my degree of power
would be higher such that I could really
affect change that I think there's a
case to be made that I'm doing more by
hosting the show particularly the bigger
it gets and I don't know that I want my
entire life to be public you know I
think that's another aspect for me most
people when they start a political
career maybe they go with like the
school board then they work up to like
city councilmen and go from there right
because you have the show and this
platform and people already know you
yeah I think you could jump right up to
like state senator or governor even I
don't know I was approached about
running for state Senate in
Massachusetts last election cycle and it
might have it was almost the way it was
presented to me Mike was was like I'd be
a shoo-in because there was either no
one running or there was someone
retiring or it was like a there was a
Republican who was in there but due to
some weird situation but it was a very
blue area but I just don't know that I
could really have the effect I want to
have through the political system I
think you would though I mean cuz I like
I watch your videos on YouTube every day
I respect you I respect your opinion on
a lot of things you know I think you're
very bright you know and I also think
your uncle and something that we need a
politics today oh boy
hey well here's an idea if I can just
wait out in the private sector until I
make enough money that I become
uncorruptible that would be the time to
go in although it's weird because you'd
think that would be the case with Trump
and it's been just swamped filling day
after day so maybe even that doesn't
make you uncut I wait I don't have
enough money to be able to tell you all
right Mike thanks for the call
appreciate it thank you have a good one
all right you too have a good New Year